(exciting music)
- [Boy] We didn't really have any
fast stackers from Texas
until he came along.
- [Boy] Like, I couldn't really
believe my eyes. Like, I was in shock.
- [Boy] His hands, like, they were
always moving, and it was like, there was no, like,
thinking about where to put it,
it was just like a non-stop, just like
(trilling)
(drum beats)
- [Boy] He's off the charts. He's
like as fast as a lightning bolt.
(drum beats)
(cups stacking)
(gentle music) (cups stacking)
- [Trey] My name is Trey Griffith,
and I'm the fastest cup stacker
in the state of Texas. My goal
is to be the fastest cup stacker
in the whole entire world.
- [Carmen] When I first saw Trey
begin cup stacking, I was thrilled.
Kids on the spectrum are always
very passionate and very intense
on what their fixation is. And he
just shined. I mean, you could
see that he was in his element.
He was comfortable, he was alive,
and he was just doin’ his thing.
- [Jimmy] Trey took it to a completely
different level. He was doing it
systematically instead of just
kinda for fun. And it was all
about getting that next best time.
What Trey does in five or six
seconds, takes me 10 or 12, 13 seconds.
We've learned not to ever discount
what he says he's gonna do.
(bright music)
- [Carmen] Sport stacking is using
a set of 12 plastic cups, and you
stack them in a very specific sequence
of pyramids, and you are racing
yourself, and you're racing a timer.
- [Jimmy] It's a sport that you
don't have to be tall, you don't
have to necessarily be able to
run quickly. As long as you've
got the 12 cups, you've got a mat,
and you've got a timer, you can stack.
To me, it's just mind-boggling
to see these stackers like Trey
and his friends. And you can tell
they're not even looking at the
cups that they're stacking. It is
all muscle memory. I mean, it's so fast
when they get to this level that
the naked eye cannot see it all.
(bright music) (cups stacking)
When I found out that I was havin’ a boy,
of course I thought about when I
was a boy, and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard, and you
flash forward, you know, thinking about
those types of things with your kiddo,
but when Trey found stacking, it was just like,
okay, cool. Here is a
sport that he's into,
and it's got speed; I've always loved
sports with speed. And it's got rhythms,
which make him happy. And I realized,
what a better way to bond with my child,
than to learn how to stack myself.
I get to stand next to my son, who's
one of the fastest in the
world, and stack with him,
and be a part of something special.
- [Carmen] Watching the
two of them stack together,
are probably some of the
best moments I've ever had.
Our motto has always been: The family
that stacks together, stays together.
We go to these tournaments together,
we’ve traveled together, we've made
friends all over the
country, all over the world.
I mean, it's definitely
enriched our lives.
(cheerful music)